stupeur à 20h dans le camp de valérie
pécresse les premières estimations
tombent la candidate des républicains
est placé en cinquième position avec 5%
des voix derrière eric zemmour c'est
d'abord le choc effectivement on se
voyait pas aussi bas on pensait que
notre projet avait réussi à convaincre
davantage de français donc c'est un état
de sidération et puis viendra le temps
collectivement de débriefer tout ça
c'est décevant parce que l amener à une
campagne
très très
forte sur un programme qui était
excellent je considère que le climat de
cette campagne l'absence de débat la
volonté d'escamoter la campagne pèse
lourd aujourd'hui dans la montée des
extrêmes et donc faudra là aussi en
tirer les conséquences à 20h15 quelques
ténors du parti arrive dans la grande
salle de la maison de la chimie à paris
valérie pécresse libre sa première
réaction suite à cette déception
l'occasion d'officialiser son vote au
second tour pour emmanuel macron tout en
soufflant une orientation à ses
électeurs je demande aux 'echos' tos
électrices et aux électeurs qui m'ont
honoré de leur confiance de peser dans
les jours qui viennent avec gravité les
conséquences potentiellement
désastreuses pour notre pays et pour les
générations futures de tout choix
différent du mien qu'il envisagerait
pour le second tour après le discours de
leur candidate les militants les
républicains qui progressivement le qg
au fil de la soirée les résultats safin
au niveau national des estimations sont
confirmées à la cinquième place valérie
pécresse obtient 4 79% des voix même
position dans les yvelines où la
candidate et les récoltes 8 32% des
suffrages juste derrière eric zemmour à
8 75%